we've heard a lot recently about the
fact that maybe the virus did start in
the lab
let's talk about that the fact that
there is this
lab i think it's the only one in the
world quite like it in wuhan
where it started it would almost be a
conspiracy theory to think it didn't
start in the lab
right and and and that theory was
demonized at first that oh it can't
come on that's conspiracy thinking that
it would start it in the lab but it
it certainly is a 50 50. would you say
that oh uh
it's far more likely than that as a
matter of fact right i said i think
in june that the chances that it came
from the lab
look to me to be about 90 okay um
so this was never a conspiracy theory in
fact that term is simply used to make it
go away
it's a an obvious hypothesis that is
in need of testing and we are only now a
year in
getting to the point where we can
discuss it out loud without being
stigmatized
okay part of the problem of course is
that
we are so politicized we are so
polarized and partisan now as a country
that if the wrong guy proposed this to
begin with
and for half the country it was the
wrong guy then the rest of the country
says no way
know how we're going to call that a
conspiracy theory and
uh and we're never going to revisit it
and the fact is that's not how science
works that is not science you need to
you need to say i've got a pattern i'm
going to make some observations and i'm
going to consider every
possible explanation on the table and
did it leak from a lab
that was clearly from the beginning a
possibility okay so let me ask you this
at first i was going to say oh when they
make me get this i'm going to i want the
mrna
because it's new i feel like it's an
improvement over the old ones
then i heard you say no even though
you're a little squirrely about it
tonight
i heard you said you want the one where
they have a little piece of the virus in
it the
way they did it for many many years
then i heard about the lab and i was
like
wait if they made that one in the lab
do i really want a little piece of that
virus in me is it possible there's
something
in a lab made virus that is different
and would make a vaccine different than
the ones we've had for decades which
were made from viruses that occurred in
nature
well this is a this is a complex topic
the adenovirus
why you're here right the adenovirus is
one that you have history with or at
least
viruses in that family you are very
unlikely to have
any evolution every evolutionary history
with beta coronaviruses which are the
ones that sardis kovi 2 comes from
so just from the point of view of what
unexpected might happen
if we give you the adenovirus vaccine
it's much less likely to be
dramatic than lipid nanoparticles which
is what the mrna vaccines are packaged
in
as far as the uh the little fragment of
dna in question or the fragment of rna
they produce the same
proteins so the target is the same the
uh the virus is wrapped the
sars sarskov2 virus is wrapped in spiked
proteins and the idea is to give those
spike proteins to the immune system
so that it recognizes them immediately
if you ever get infected
and from that point of view the the the
vaccines that are currently available
are equivalent they're all delivering so
you're not worried if it was made in the
lab that it would be different
that a vaccine would be different made
from that that was that came from a lab
instead of nature itself which i mean
the lab is taking nature itself of
course
yes that doesn't concern you all of our
best tricks we are borrowing from nature
right in case we are just simply taking
that spike protein and figuring out how
to get it into your cells so that your
immune system gets a chance to see it
so if but let's assume that the chinese
were not trying to create a bio weapon
it's possible that they were
if they were they did a hell of a job
because they shut down the world
but let's assume they were just studying
this for
elemonary reasons we want it we want to
have them but it got out
maybe like on a worker's you know it's
like when the busboy doesn't wash his
hands before he goes to the bathroom and
you know then you get food poisoning but
for the whole world right
right that's what happened okay so
okay so that got out it raises the
question
should we ever be studying viruses and
labs this way
if we're just going to create the
problem that we're trying to
well that battle was taking place before
the
covet 19 epidemic there was uh there
were two factions there was a faction
that said we had no choice but to study
these viruses and in fact to engage in
what's called gain of function research
where we turbocharge
the viruses and make them much more
dangerous than they are in the condition
we find them
and the argument was that we had to do
that in order to know what they would be
like
in their dangerous form and could
perhaps prepare by
generating a vaccine and then there was
another faction that said
actually we're likely to create exactly
the disaster we fear
and what was missing from this
discussion was a proper evolutionary
analysis
now the fact is there are lots of
viruses that can escape from nature
and infect people but in general they
don't have a second trick
that is to say they can infect you they
can make you sick maybe they can kill
you
but they can't jump to the next person
and so what's really conspicuous about
this virus
is that it had both tricks from the
get-go it
infects people and it differs from one
person to the next with no explanation
and now it seems to be having a third
trick which is it's mutating which of
course is not new
viruses are always mutating that's why
flu shots are very often so ineffective
because you're getting the vaccine for
that's why i never wanted a flu shot for
the one that was around last year
sometimes they're they're as little as
10 effective but okay so
this one is definitely mutating we have
a lot of them
now the south african one the british
one
they're all over the world now uh
i heard at the beginning of this that
they usually get milder
viruses as they mutate because they want
to survive they don't want to kill
anybody then they got no host
you might expect that a virus that did
emerge
from a lab that was doing gain of
function research would precisely not do
the thing
that wild-type viruses would do that it
might exactly do
what we seem to be seeing get more
virulent get more pathogenic
you think it's getting more virulent the
mutations if
you think about it the the expectation
amongst those who have been seriously
investigating the question
of whether this is a gain of function uh
lab escape
virus is that the virus would have been
passed through either animals in the lab
or tissues in the lab in order to use
evolution
to re-rig it and that means that
effectively tension was
put on the virus pulling it in the
direction of certain
things some of those things were
intentional like infectivity of human
cells
which may have given it extra capacities
like this
this fern cleavage site that no other
virus like this has but sarsko v2
does so in any case in an attempt
to give it these extra capacities lots
of things will have been
inflicted on the virus including things
that we don't think about
so many of the characteristics the fact
that this virus attacks so many
different tissues in the body
does not seem natural the fact that it
does not at least at the beginning did
not seem to transmit outdoors
nearly at all is very conspicuous i mean
after all
most animals live outdoors so a virus
that seems to be adapted to indoor
transmission is a bit conspicuous in
this case
but i think heather's point is all right
you take the tension off of it you
let it go into the human population it
spreads out we've now got many
millions of individuals with infections
it's now going to
move in the direction that makes the
most sense for it rather than the most
sense for the researchers
so yes i think there's every possibility
that
what we are seeing is um a response to
this virus now being free to explore
evolutionary space
and the common theme is we need an
evolutionary perspective
on the research that's being done it
seems that there is
there are certainly perverse incentives
to once you start doing research to try
to keep doing that research regardless
of whether or not it's still good for
humanity
right and excuse me um
whether or not this virus
emerged from a lab or not actually has
implications for how it is likely to
behave now that it's out in the world
and how therefore we should we should
imagine how likely these things are
going to be going forward
so we should have been paying attention
to the lab theory at the beginning but
we didn't because it was politicized
really is the moral there
you